welcome to the david pakman show i'm
farin cousins and i'm going to be
sitting in for david for these next two
days we've got a lot to cover today of
course we've had
more from the january 6 committee we've
had more from the documentary film that
is now a central piece of evidence in
those hearings we're going to be talking
about all that plus marjorie taylor
green's week-long meltdown
among many other stories so let's jump
right into it
and i want to start by of course talking
about the january 6 hearings
and the big takeaway that i have had
from all of these hearings we have seen
so far everything that's come out of the
committee and pretty much anything
that's been revealed
since january 6th of 2021
is that had donald trump
had a more competent team working for
him
i think his coup
would have gone a lot differently and
not of course in a good way for the
united states
so think about this for a moment one of
the things we learned earlier this week
was that mark meadows was actually
actually offering state officials uh
free
maga stuff including autographed maga
gear
if officials were you know willing to
toss out their state's 2020 election
results
not exactly
a big selling point right
you know like hey we know it's
unconstitutional we know you're going to
have to break the law but
we're going to throw in a free hat how
does that sound right
nobody in their right mind is going to
take that offer
and then of course we have
mike lindell
who has been spearheading the efforts to
overturn the 2020 election results to
this very day
attorneys like sydney powell and john
eastman and rudy giuliani
all of this cast of just absolute
weirdos
working to overturn the 2020 election
and all of them in my opinion
equally incompetent
and that's the thing though
had any of these individuals
been switched out by somebody that maybe
actually knew what they were doing you
know somebody with a little bit of a
brain in their heads
trump could have succeeded
you know switch out sydney powell and
rudy giuliani
and substitute in bill barr
suddenly that becomes a lot scarier if
the attorney general of the united
states had gone along with this plan
he would have been able to use
the power of the doj there would have
been enough people inside the doj to try
to carry out these plans
think for a second if instead of mike
lindell going out there and selling this
to the public which hasn't gone very
well for him
what if it was karl rove instead
things would have been a lot different
rove is a master at messaging he's an
expert manipulator whereas of course
mike lindell just comes across as you
know
a bit of an unhinged kind of guy
he's the pillow man for god's sakes
but you switch out
any one of these little weirdos
for somebody with even a little bit of
competence a little bit of credibility
suddenly we're looking at a very
different scenario in the united states
today
and of course
therein lies the bigger problem for the
future
donald trump of course and all other
republicans who might be planning
something similar they've all learned
from these mistakes
right they know the kind of people that
they need to put in place
and how do we know that they've learned
from this
well you need to look no further than
steve bannon for more than a year now
ever since trump left office really on
his podcast steve bannon has been one of
the leading cheerleaders telling these
maga folks out here across the country
go run for office
go become a poll worker
run for secretary of state run for
governor
put yourselves in the position
to where this
you know the allegedly stolen 2020
election which wasn't stolen but put
yourself in the position
to where you can do something about it
in the future
the framework has been laid down
okay it's not in the planning phases the
the framework is there now
to a degree
maybe not to enough of a degree to
actually overturn election results but
they're getting close
and they could be a heck of a lot closer
after this year's midterms and it all
goes back to learning from their
mistakes
they knew
or they know now they didn't know at the
time but they know now
that the people they had running this
whole thing
were wholly incompetent
so you replace them with more competent
individuals you replace them with people
who know how to get things done you
replace them with loyal lap dogs who are
not gonna tell you no
that of course has been one of trump's
driving factors with his endorsements so
far in the primary season that's why he
tried so desperately to get brian kemp
and brad raffensberger out of the state
of georgia
because he wants people that would not
tell him no
if he were to ask them to break the law
and it's already happening
again not to not to the degree that he
would like to see it or that other
republicans would like to see it
but it is happening
they know where their weak links were in
2021 on january 6th
and more and more of them of course are
being exposed by these january 6
hearings
and they're not going to make the same
mistake twice
and again that to me is where the real
danger lies it's great that we're
exposing everything that happened that
has to be done
we also have to hold them criminally
accountable for it
but
we can't you know once this is over wipe
our hands like cool case closed we've
saved democracy no
that threat is still out there
and that again is kind of the underlying
theme
of these hearings
it's been the underlying theme also for
the record
of the judges overseeing the cases of
the capitol rioters
they have said that plenty of these
people
we've seen how they've been essentially
brainwashed
and we believe it can happen again we
believe these people are still dangerous
that's why a lot of the judges
overseeing these cases have been annoyed
when prosecutors you know reduce the
charges down to misdemeanors the judges
want to put these people in jail
because they're afraid it's going to
happen again
we're getting reports from the
department of homeland security
you know to expect violence another
report came out yesterday
warning of the increased risk of
violence here in the united states as we
head into the midterms and all of it
goes back to january 6 folks
every bit of it
is tied back to that
because all these people from trump
down to his supporters and everybody in
between
they learned from their mistakes
and it's unlikely that they would be
making those same mistakes again
one of our sponsors today is bluechew a
unique online service delivering the
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis in a chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost and they're giving
my audience an entire month supply for
free so if you think you could benefit
from an extra boost of confidence
when it's time
all you have to do is take a short quiz
on their website a licensed doctor
approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days in a discrete package no
driving around to the doctor's office or
the pharmacy no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of blue chews tablets are made in
the usa the entire process is just a few
clicks
go to bluechew.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free when
you use the promo code pacman all you
have to do is pay five dollars shipping